speaking of bigger and better things
over the weekend the david pakman show
YouTube channel achieved and surpassed
600,000 subscribers which is such an
exciting milestone particularly because
it happened so quickly after 500,000
subscribers it feels like just yesterday
although it was a few months ago that I
was telling you about five hundred
thousand subscribers and now we have
reached six hundred thousand subscribers
and YouTube has just been such a great
platform for us and I was thinking back
to the first month that we were on
YouTube and I was looking at our
analytics and we had 721 views okay I'm
not talking about 720 views per hour or
721 views per video the first month we
were on YouTube
we had 721 views total okay we had four
subscribers after our first month on
YouTube the second month that we were on
YouTube
we went from 721 views to 948 views and
we gained five more subscribers okay so
after two months on YouTube we had
roughly 1,700 views and nine subscribers
even in the entire second year on
YouTube an entire year now not a month
we had about two million views and 3,200
new subscribers we are now regularly
adding fifteen to twenty thousand
subscribers per month and 10 to 12
million views each month on the YouTube
channel
it is truly stunning I have just our
audience to thank and I know that we've
had our ups and downs on YouTube ad
pocalypse in the middle of 2017 which
took away nearly 99% of our revenue
we've dealt with video D monetization
because we aren't producing the videos
that will be monetized we're producing
the videos that we believe are important
to our audience copyright claims
including bogus and fraudulent ones all
of that stuff that we've dealt with we
never fully recovered the ad revenue
side since ad pocalypse but the audience
size
has just continued to explode and I I
mean just thank you thank you to the now
more than six hundred and one thousand
subscribers that we have and to
celebrate this we are doing something
that is themed with the number six okay
six hundred thousand subscribers we are
offering sixty memberships at sixty
percent off okay mostly we're funded by
membership especially since ad pocalypse
where YouTube ad revenue has been very
very erratic and unpredictable
membership gets you extra content just
for members thanks to members we
weathered ad pocalypse and the deal is
since we've hit six hundred thousand
subscribers I'm calling it sixty four
sixty sixty memberships for 60% off it's
first-come first-served okay if you want
to get a yearly membership 60% off drops
it to just twenty four dollars for the
year that's two dollars a month most of
the people in our audience can afford
that sixty people in the audience
definitely can afford it if you want to
do a monthly membership a sixty percent
discount
drops it to two dollars and forty cents
a month it's first-come first-served
okay you've got to get in touch with me
personally I'm personally managing these
sixty memberships you can use the
contact form on our website you can just
email me directly that's probably
quicker and and just more efficient
david at david pakman.com david at david
pakman.com you just say David I want one
of the 60 memberships and I will write
you back with a one-time use coupon code
which will save you $60 off of the
membership of your choice that's 600
thousand and onward and upward to
700,000 then who knows maybe we'll do 70
memberships at 70 percent off at that
time but don't wait that just take
advantage of 60 percent off right now it
could be another year before we get to
700,000 but very exciting stuff in a
great milestone coming in the same week
by the way that we announced that we are
launching or did launch the show on W
CPT the biggest progressive radio
station in Chicago and also will soon be
launching on television
in Washington DC so a great week or two
for the David Pakman show